max boo was on msnbc again this week
guess what he was talking about can you
guess the one thing that brings joy to
his stunted and miserable existence and
that's war other people burning each
other to death
max boot announced a new escalation in
his new favorite war the war in ukraine
listen to this
i think the key here is we have to
understand that we're making a mistake
in the way that we think about the war
because we keep thinking about it as
their war the ukrainians are fighting we
need to think about it as our war we're
not providing great eagle drones that
the ukrainians need we're not providing
as many multiple launch rocket systems
as they need all of us collectively can
be and should be doing more because we
need to understand this is our fight
that the ukrainians are on the front
lines of it's our war hear that people
of
dubuque bangor gulfport spokane it's
your war not theirs but the weird thing
is despite the fact it's our war max
boot is still in the morning joe studio
wearing soft shoes
so despite this war's world historic
importance and our own personal
ownership of it max boot is not actually
fighting
his war
nor even more strangely is max boot
sending his own salary to fund our war
what he's doing is what he always does
which is promoting our war and this is
hardly the first war
in boots long and not at all varied
career as a war promoter he has demanded
that american troops go to war in a
dizzying variety of countries buddhists
call for invasions of syria
invasion of iran as well as a hot war
against north korea even a war against
saudi arabia quote if the us armed
forces made such short work of a
hardened goon like saddam hussein
imagine what they could do to the soft
and siberic saudi royal family boot once
wrote and he was imagining it in great
detail
what didn't happen we never invaded
mecca too bad so max blue moved on to
calling for the military occupation of
pakistan
pakistan nuclear armed pakistan let's
occupy it and then somalia those were
our wars too in 2011 boot called for war
against libya and hillary clinton
actually did it and of course boot was
one of the main cheerleaders for our war
against iraq quote once we have deposed
saddam he wrote before the invasion we
can impose an american-led international
regency in baghdad to go along with the
one in kabul
to turn a rock into a beacon of hope for
the oppressed peoples of the middle east
now that would be a historic war aim is
this an ambitious agenda without a doubt
does america have the resources to carry
it out also without a doubt
sure
we can afford it it'll be easy
now trillions of dollars more than a
million dead people later how did max
boots prediction work out
don't ask
he's got a new war to sell you it's our
war
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight